So let's start with a big
question, one that's really
personal but also cuts deep into
American history.
What does it actually mean to
belong here in America?
Right.
And was this country ever really
intended to be just one thing?
You know, one single uniform
identity.
Exactly.
These are the questions swirling
around the piece we're diving
into today.
Yeah, it's this really
fascinating and very personal
article by Chris Abraham.
It's called Poi Dogs Impurity
Tests.
Why America was Never an ethnic
ethno state.
And it started apparently, from
reflecting on a tense
conversation, but it spiraled
into this much deeper look at
his own past, his memories, and
what it means to be American.
So our mission for you in this
deep dive is really to unpack
Abraham's argument, his core
idea that America fundamentally
was never set up to be an ethno
state.
And we'll see how his own life
story, his experiences, shed
light on these really complex
ideas, identity, belonging, even
how the definition of whiteness
keeps changing.
Hopefully it gives you a more
nuanced way to think about being
American.
Let's.
Jump in.
OK, so Abraham kicks things off
back when he was 6.
He's in Salt Lake, Oahu, living
in this pretty modest garden
apartment complex near the
airport.
Right, and he describes himself
as a hail kid.
Yeah, Irish, English, German,
Czechoslovakian, Hungarian,
quite a mix.
And his friends also mix kids
name Sukhai Maida Chen.
Japanese, Korean, Filipino,
Chinese, Samoan.
Really diverse.
And he had this great term for
all of them together.
Poi dogs.
Which means basically mutt kids,
but proud of it, proud of the,
you know, the stories in their
blood.
Such a cool image of childhood,
but then things changed.
He did, he says.
By Intermediate School, that
pride, that whole poi dog
identity, it started to fade.
Now, so suddenly, he wasn't this
unique mix anymore.
He was just white, or just hail,
as he puts it, and he describes
it feeling like an erasure, like
a flattening of all the specific
parts of him.
His dad's stoic German grit.
His mom's Irish laughter.
His grandmother's hushed check
prayers.
Wow, that's specific.
You can feel the loss there.
Totally, he says.
That memory still lives in him,
and it really seems to be the
seed for this whole exploration.
He also mentions a really nice
detail about his first friend
right Frank Park.
Ohio.
Yeah, that's lovely.
Frank Park, whose mom would
grill Colby and introduced him
to kimchi.
He says the flavor lit something
up in him and he.
Still eats it, The Korean store
downstairs.
It shows how those early mixed
experiences really stay with
you.
Absolutely.
That personal feeling, that
sense of being flattened, it
directly leads him to ask this
bigger question.
Was America ever meant to be an
ethno state?
And he has a pretty clear
answer.
Very clear, he says.
I don't think so.
In fact, I know it wasn't.
OK, So what was it then,
According to him?
Chaos.
Basically, he paints a picture
of the beginnings as chaotic,
contradictory, alive with
migration, with faiths, with
fractured languages and fragile
alliances.
Not exactly unified vision.
Not at all.
His main point is purity wasn't
the project.
The project was possibility.
Possibility.
Like, I like that it's less
about a fixed identity and more
about potential, an ongoing
thing.
Exactly.
It reframes the whole narrative
and he tackles the idea of
America's original sin.
Which he doesn't see as
diversity itself.
No, he sees it as hypocrisy, the
huge contradiction of dreaming
of liberty while being built on
slavery.
But even with that massive
hypocrisy, he insists even then,
this land was a Stew.
It wasn't monolithic.
And he gives examples.
Yep.
Straight from the source.
Free black citizens before
slavery fully industrialized,
but Jews in New Amsterdam, Even
the fact that Hawaiian royalty
once visited the White House.
So layers of complexity from the
very start.
Which leads to his simple
conclusion.
We've always been messy.
And this messiness, he argues,
is fundamentally different from
actual ethno states.
Right.
He contrasts the US with places
like Japan, Korea, Hungary.
There, he says, ancestry is law
and legitimacy flows through
blood.
Meaning immigrants, even those
born there, often remain
outsiders.
Pretty much.
He points out that that even
second or third generation
immigrants often live as
outsiders.
Assimilation isn't really on the
table because it isn't offered.
That's the stark difference.
It is, and he makes this
interesting observation that
somehow America gets judged more
harshly for failing at perfect
inclusion than these other
countries are for not even
trying.
Like we're held to the standard
of our own possibility, even
when we fall short.
You can say that, and this idea
of shifting standards leads him
to look at whiteness itself in
America.
Saying it, it wasn't always what
we think it is now.
Exactly.
He argues forcefully that
whiteness in America has never
been stable.
He lists the groups Irish
weren't white, Italians weren't
white.
Jews weren't white.
Slabs weren't white.
So what was it then, if not just
skin color?
He defines it as a constantly
shifting proximity to power.
Like a gatekeeping system, the
rules change depending on who
the powerful wanted to let in or
keep out at any given moment.
Power, not just pigment.
That's a key distinction.
It really is.
It reframes whiteness as more
about social and economic access
than genetics.
Which brings us to today's
identity conversations.
He has some critiques there too,
right?
He does, he points out, a kind
of inconsistency.
He sees people will demand,
quite rightly, the most exacting
forms of nuance for themselves,
like.
Distinguishing between Dominican
and Puerto Rican or Korean and
Japanese.
Exactly insisting on those
important specifics.
But then, he says, those same
people might turn around and
reduce every pale skinned person
to white.
And he feels that's not
progress.
He says flatly, that's not
justice, that's just reversal.
It feels like a strong call for
genuine, consistent pluralism.
Saying if we want pluralism, we
have to mean it.
That means everyone gets a seat,
even people like me meeting
people with European backgrounds
like him.
Right, and it connects to this
plea he makes for listening to
all pain, including those who
are quietly hurting.
People who don't want to
dominate but also don't want to
be told they don't belong in the
conversation at all.
It's a call for broader empathy,
basically, to recognize
complexity everywhere.
And this complexity isn't just
an American thing.
He shares a really jarring
personal story that takes this
global.
Yeah, this is quite something.
He talks about an encounter on
Mastodon with an actual white
supremacist.
In what?
Happened.
This person told him point blank
that because he's Irish,
Hungarian, American and
Catholic, he wasn't really
white.
Seriously, what was the logic
there?
The logic, if you can call it
that, was that true whiteness
was only for the True
Bloodlines, ethnic English and
Germans.
They even used the British
monarchy as supposed proof.
Wow.
So even within whiteness there
are these brutal hierarchies.
Absolutely, and the labels
thrown at Abraham were awful.
Cultural mimic mud, blood,
garbage, people, even
untermensch the Nazi term for
subhuman.
That's deeply disturbing.
How did he process that?
He talks about finding power in
naming what others use to shame.
He connects it to reading the
book Bloodlands and thinking
about the language of the
underman and.
He uses this awful experience to
make a broader point about
hierarchies everywhere.
Exactly.
He broadens the lens gives
examples like Singapore, where
social status can be tied to Han
Chinese lines, or Finland, where
historically Swedish elites held
power over native fins.
So his point is even in
supposedly homogeneous
societies.
Someone is always deemed less
than.
There's always an in Group and
an out group.
Which reinforces his core
argument about purity.
Yes, that purity is a myth used
to exclude, not elevate.
It's never about lifting
everyone up, it's about pushing
some people down.
South, If purity is the problem,
what's the alternative?
He points towards?
Where does he go from here?
Well.
He doesn't offer easy answers,
but he does bring it back to
thinking about justice, class
opportunity.
He even specifically says we
should talk about Ubi, universal
basic income.
Interesting, why Ubi?
He has this insight about how
sometimes grievance and sedation
can sometimes do the same thing,
meaning meaning they can both
stop people from striving, keep
them just comfortable enough or
just angry enough to stay put,
to stop reaching for more.
He calls that management, not
freedom.
That's provocative, suggesting
that even things meant to help
could potentially dampen that
possibility.
He values so much.
Right.
It challenges you to think about
what true freedom and
opportunity look like.
And this leads him to his final
thoughts on America itself.
It does.
He ends with this really
powerful statement of belief in
the country.
But not, he stresses, because
it's pure, but because it's
unfinished.
That's the key.
He has that line.
It's the only place I know where
poi dogs can speak.
Yeah, it beautifully brings it
back to his childhood, that mix,
that potential.
His final thought really sums it
up.
No, America isn't an ethno
state.
And the very fact that we try to
include everyone.
Even when we fail is something
extraordinary.
It's the attempt, the
aspiration, that matters to him.
So it is messy, but as he says,
it's ours and.
I'll defend that with Aloha.
A perfect ending, bringing in
the spirit of his Hawaiian
upbringing.
So wrapping up our deep dive
today, Chris Abraham's story
gives us this really personal,
compelling argument against the
whole idea of America as some
kind of ethno state.
Yeah, he really leans into the
historical messiness, the
contradictions, but also that
unique American capacity for for
possibility and how identity
itself is always shifting here.
And hearing it through his
personal lens, you know, it's a
way to get at these big ideas
that maybe feels more direct,
gives you those aha moments you
might miss in a dryer.
Purely historical account.
Definitely.
It makes the abstract feel
concrete.
So here's a final thought for
you to chew on.
Building on Abraham's idea, he
says America is unfinished.
What does that mean for you
personally being part of an
unfinished project?
How might seeing it that way
shape your own sense of
belonging?
Or maybe how you interact with
all the different stories and
people around you.